sur ce plateau deux piliers du club de
rugby de plaisir pour nous parler des
bonnes prestations de l'équipe seniors
le manager général Sébastien rocali et
l'ailier Hugo a Taillandier bonsoir
messieurs rebonsoir monsieur alors
plaisir est actuellement deuxième du
championnat de Fédérale 2 est-ce que
vous attendiez un tel début de saison
Sébastien
on espérait en tout cas dans la
continuité du travail effectué sur les
cinq dernières années on Fédérale 2 et
notamment l'année dernière où on loupe
la qualification de deux points sur un
match en retard qu'on a pas pu jouer
donc voilà on était très frustré malgré
les bons résultats et euh un bon
enchaînement de victoire notamment sur
une grosse équipe de Nantes où là
c'était vraiment un très très bel
exploit à la maison on espérait cette
année effectivement être dans les 6 et
effectivement on se retrouve deuxième
après un beau parcours sur les matchs
aller donc aujourd'hui oui on espère
confirmer sur les matchs retours Hugo
vous êtes d'accord avec votre coach a
toujours on a bougé
au classement maintenant c'est ça
continue par le par le travail et par le
sérieux de de chacun mais on est sur sur
une bonne une bonne voie et on a la
chance d'avoir un collectif qui qui a
aussi l'envie de bien faire et de et de
continuer cette belle aventure non il y
a eu trois défaites tout de même sur
cette première partie de saison est-ce
que elle vous reste en travers de la
gorge ou justement comme la première
partie de saison est réussie elles sont
un peu oubliées c'est des fêtes
Sébastien sont très frustrantes
également parce que bah c'est des
défaites on en a deux petits points une
de ces points de 5 points de 8 points
donc c'est trois matchs qu'on aurait pu
accrocher
malgré tout ça reste très positif parce
qu'il y a qu'un match je comprends pas
de points c'est au Havre paire de 8
points mais c'est vrai que sur le
contenu
on pouvait espérer mais ouais laquelle
vous énerve le plus peut-être Courbevoie
à la maison
et est-ce que votre équipe vous surprend
ou pas Sébastien roncalier est-ce que
vous sentiez que il y avait cette
possibilité d'aller chercher peut-être
une peut-être en fin de saison
non je suis pas surpris mais c'est vrai
que il confirme quoi encore une fois
d'aller en année il confirme là cette
année ils sont arrivés on a eu un nombre
de 50 60 joueurs qui sont arrivés
mi-août en forme c'est des choses qui
étaient pas forcément arrivées dans les
années passées Parce que le rugby
amateur c'est pas toujours simple de
faire les choses dans le bon sens à ce
niveau-là mais là les mecs sont arrivés
très très en forme ce qui expliquent
aussi certainement ce bon début et
comment vous expliquer justement ce
changement de mentalité peut-être qui
est encore plus professionnel si je peux
dire au sein de Rugby Club de c'est je
pense que c'est l'envie de bien faire et
puis en fait on a aussi un staff qui est
qui s'entend bien et sans le ressent
aussi en tant que en tant que joueur et
je pense que c'est important aussi
d'avoir la confiance et être dans
l'échange et en fait tous les choses se
font très naturellement parce que quand
on a de la confiance quand on peut
dialoguer et quand on peut discuter de
plein de choses que ça soit sur le
terrain ou en dehors de terrain ben le
résultat ça se ressent et c'est
important pour pour ce qui se passe le
dimanche tout simplement le groupe vit
bien le groupe vit très très bien il y a
un bon mélange entre les entre les
anciens
exactement ça c'est aussi ce qu'on en
parlait avec Sébastien c'est il y a un
mélange qui se fait et puis il y a des
générations qui arrivent et tout le
monde est accepté et ça c'est aussi
hyper important c'est ça aussi qui fait
la force de votre groupe aujourd'hui et
puis on a eu aussi la porte tous les ans
de 1 2 3 joueurs qui nous ont rejoint de
l'extérieur et qui ont été totalement
dans l'esprit du club et qui sont
parfaitement intégrés et qui permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir comme disait Hugo un
groupe homogène de garçon qui sont
tournés vers la le même objectif et on a
au-delà des résultats l'équipe première
on a aussi une équipe B qui tourne très
très bien et c'est pour ça qu'on a une
concurrence saine et voilà un très bel
état d'esprit dans tout tout va dans le
bon sens et sur quoi vous devez
travailler du coup coach
on a toujours des tas de choses à
travailler dans notre sport on a
tellement de domaines de travail et
encore une fois nous dans le sport
amateur en fait beaucoup d'analyses
vidéos on a très peu de temps
effectivement et justement par rapport à
ce travail là vidéo nous on n'est pas
sur des possibilités de voir nos gâteaux
tous les jours donc voilà c'est un
travail
constant permanent et voilà on arrive à
trouver des petits moments où on peut
échanger avec les joueurs sur ce sujet
ouais en début de saison on était venu
vous voir à l'occasion du derby de cette
fédéral de face à Versailles il y avait
une belle victoire à l'époque voilà vous
nous disiez que l'objectif c'était
d'atteindre au moins les phases finales
pour pour cette saison est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'objectifs montés ou l'objectif
reste inchangé c'est déjà de valider
votre place dans ces phases finales non
premier lieu ouais c'est effectivement
validé notre place dans les phases
finales puisqu'on fait des L2 on l'a
jamais connu donc ça c'est le premier
gros objectif mais effectivement bah là
j'ai envie de vous dire la petit vient
en mangeant donc
on en parle forcément on prépare
l'avenir parce que si ça doit arriver il
faut être prêt pour pour cet événement
c'est la motivation pour les joueurs
cette possibilité
bien sûr c'est une grosse motivation
quand on parlait pas de monter il y a
deux trois ans et puis on se rend compte
que on est quand même maintenant un
statut où on est attendu quand on vient
se quand on vient un peu se frotter un
peu à plaisir à domicile bah c'est
jamais simple on entend de plus en plus
ouais plaisir ça fait des ça fait des
bons résultats et oui ce serait ce
serait magnifique même au-delà de ça
sportivement pour un groupe c'est c'est
quelque chose de beau et puis si on peut
réussir pourquoi pas aller chercher
cette fédérale une ce serait quand même
quelque chose de très beau et puis
beaucoup de souvenirs aussi donc ouais
étape par étape ou euh clairement
l'afficher étape par étape voilà là il y
en a une reprise qui va être importante
capitale ça c'est une belle équipe de
Ris-Orangis qui nous a battu au match
aller donc on sait que ça va pas être
simple vous parliez de nos amis de
Versailles qui nous attend dans la
continuité le week-end d'après la
prochaine question justement le derby
vers contre Versailles qui est sixième
du classement de fédéral 2 donc ça sera
un gros match ah oui oui qu'on sera on
sera bien reçu et ça sera forcément un
gros match en plus certes ils ont pris
quelques points chez nous à la maison
mais depuis ils font des bons résultats
on voit qu'ils travaillent bien on voit
que ça progresse aussi chez eux voilà
ils ont découvert cette année le niveau
mais bon je pense qu'ils seront vraiment
prêts là je sais qu'ils étaient en stage
le week-end dernier donc voilà
oui bien sûr bien sûr bah toujours
pareil par le biais de la vidéo même à
notre niveau c'est de plus en plus
fréquent que les équipes se filment et
travaille avec donc effectivement on
arrive toujours à avoir des images pour
vous demander pour la monter si je
comprends bien
ça sera la même réponse et un mot très
rapide sur le match de ce dimanche on en
a parlé face à l'Histoire enregistre
réception de Ris-Orangis qui est sixième
au classement si je dis pas de bêtises
un mot sur sur ce match tout est tout
est prêt pour ce match
non après on sait que ça va être
difficile voilà c'est une équipe aussi
qui travaille bien ils sont montés en
même temps que nous hein il y a 5 ans si
je m'abuse il y a 6 ans donc on est un
peu sur le même profil de club et de
travail voilà ils ont des ambitions
aussi voilà encore une fois je vous dis
ce match là on sait que voilà c'est le
le tournant pour pouvoir prétendre après
justement à une évolution ou pas
c'est tout le mal que l'on peut vous
souhaiter pour pour cette fin de saison